The joe rogan experience.
Yeah,
and he's like,
like a top scientist should
have died after the uh,
appendicitis.
I'm one of the week.
I just,
it's just no way.
He's like one of the rare guys that
three Jiu Jitsu classes I tapped out for.
Good.
I'm out.
You should come.
Come,
come with me tonight man.
Look,
I know I'm not a man.
Would love,
I don't need to go down there and have
it reinforced all you guys get this
pressure side.
Is it a calm me down
and make you feel better
dude,
I'm like the commerce
I've been in my life.
I'm always going to sound like I'm in a
bad mood because I have the east coast
accent.
Look dude,
your fucking phony.
Calm down.
You're like,
you're,
you're you,
you smoke weed.
Why calm down from exercise to I.
We doesn't necessarily calm me down
as it does make me just a little more
sensitive.
Red Redman you buying this?
I think we'd calmed me down.
Yeah.
Dude,
you are a completely different person.
Like when I met you in like
96 97 you are good guy,
but you wouldn't want the most
intense fucking dude's I never met.
It was like this switch somewhere in your
life was flipped and the shit was on.
I don't even know how you slept.
You were like,
you are like,
ah,
fucking goal line defense,
middle linebacker.
That's shit doesn't mean anything to you.
I'm using sports analogies like you were
fucking intense to and every story I
heard about you at Taekwondo,
uh,
events,
I believed all of it after meeting
you for literally about 25 seconds.
Well I,
I was transitioning then still.
That was still just a few years.
Sounds like a guy trying to mix the role.
No,
it was true.
He was transgender when I was a,
when I was a young guy.
Crazy.
Or when I was younger,
I was going through my entire,
my entire childhood was spent competing
in martial arts tournaments from the
time I was like 15 to the time
I was 22 was my last fight.
So do you think it made you like that
or it tapped into something that was
already there?
I don't think I would have been that
intense if I didn't have to deal with
really dangerous shit on a regular basis.
It was the fact that you were fighting
in tournament's on a regular basis and
nothing ever happened to me.
I never got hurt,
but I easily could've easily could zig
when I should have zagged and got knocked
the fuck out.
It just never happened.
I only lost once in a kickboxing
match and that was not,
not that I didn't lose
a before and taekwondo,
but lost once by stoppage.
The only time I ever got stopped
was in a kickboxing match.
That was the third fight in a day and
I was terrible nutrition back then,
always getting sick,
you know,
it didn't really take vitamins and shit
and that was on the fence back then.
I was like doing stand up and
fighting at the same time,
so it wasn't like a bad knock out.
I got dropped by a left hook
and then I got up and I,
my,
my legs just wouldn't work and he hit
me again and I fell down again and they
stopped the fight.
Like it was just a,
he had hit my jaw like in the
perfect spot and everything gave out.
And I was thinking about
it like when I was,
when I was going back that there's
one of two things I'm gonna do.
Either I'm going to go fucking crazy now
and rededicate myself and try to be a
world champion kickboxer and just use
the fact that I got tired in the third
fight of the day as motivation to just
run extra miles and do extra plyometrics
and do extra rounds or be a standup.
Yeah,
no brainer.
I was like,
I can't,
there's no,
there's no reward.
There was no ultimate fighting
championship back then.
There was no,
so it's like I had to reprogram my brain.
I ended up pro my,
my brain was used to always thinking
about martial arts competition.
That's all it was.
It was dodging kicks,
landing your own,
you know,
getting in,
closing the distance.
And you know,
and,
and forcing your game plan.
That's what my whole day was
spent fighting in my head.
Even if I wasn't finding it would be
fighting in my head what I was when I was
a,
like I had girlfriends,
we,
they'd sleep over and uh,
I would,
I would throw kicks in the middle
of the night like don't like my,
my whole body would jolt like a kick
cause I was having a fighting dream.
So I was terrified.
I was constantly terrified.
I got really good at it because
I was absolutely horrified of it.
I just didn't want to,
I just did not want to get my ass
kicked and I was already doing it.
I'm like,
well this is what we're doing then we've
got to get really fucking good at this
because this is not something you can
half ass dudes are kicking dudes in the
face and knocking people unconscious.
Like this is fucking terrifying.
I saw it happens so many times.
Saw happened to good friends.
I saw it happen to people
who are better than me.
They just fought the wrong
dude at the wrong time,
which easily could have happened to me.
It didn't,
but it easily could have like a,
our instructor never protected us at all.
He put us even,
we were like,
kids were teenagers.
He would put us in the
men's division and you know,
and tell you like,
you're good enough to fight as a black
belt when you were like a blue belt or
red belt.
He was just,
he wanted to see who is crazy.
He wanted to see,
he wanted to develop a team of
people who didn't give a fuck.
That's so funny that you,
you could do that with kids.
Like that guy.
He can on the,
the like at the very least local news,
you know,
it was very cold
ditch.
The martial arts schools are very cultish.
It's,
yes sir.
No Sir.
It's all like almost military,
you know,
like it's always bowing when you see him,
you always bow.
You always call him sir.
It was very,
yeah,
I can,
I never been able to exist in that
dynamic no matter what it was like,
there's no way I could,
uh,
I needed it.
I grew up without a dad.
I grew up without a,
I have a Stepdad,
but my real dad,
I knew he was alive and I
didn't communicate with them,
so it always fucked with me.
So I needed some sort of intense
discipline to get my shit together.
So first time I ever felt like I had
any control of my life at all was when I
started doing martial arts.
I was like,
oh,
finally,
I can fucking get good at something.
This,
I'm good at this shit.
You know?
But,
so that's why I was so wound up met.
It took me a while to relax.
You know,
it's so amazing how we've been
able to cut that out of our lives.
That whole food gathering nonsense.
Like while I was watching this mountain
men show and watched this poor guy with
shitty rodeo knees.
He's going out looking for deer,
like trying to get a deer,
some meat for the freezer while
he's looking for bears constantly.
Like what,
what an amazing change of life it's
happened when they figured out how to cut
out that whole gathering food
that was already bad enough.
Bad knees looking for a deer.
And then he does the,
the,
the over the top wild looking for bears.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
You got to watch the show.
It's a great show.
No,
that's why I just watched it
last night for the first time.
I'm comfortable being in the Matrix.
I,
you know,
I'll,
I'll starve to death and it will be a
brutal month and then that'll be it.
I don't want to be walking around with
my bad back out in the fucking moments
trying to shoot deer in the face,
trying to get it with
some sharpened stick,
Gabby.
All right.
I'm,
I'm part of the week.
I'm not supposed to be here.
That's just someone like you,
you,
you'll,
you'll tap back into your,
uh,
when you through kicks in at night.
Yeah.
I'll just grow grass mountain man.
Beard.
That's where animal
skins make my own spears.
I just,
that's the name of good,
uh,
Bruce Springsteen album make,
make my own spirit.
When I threw kicks in the night
through kicks him.
If you said something,
I have to be like a breakup margin,
Lou one man.
There's something about being young and
getting out of the town and getting away
from all the boozers and then you go into
the course when it kicks in the night.
Okay.